graph x is less than four so let's draw
ourselves a number line over here so let
me draw
a number line
let me put i'll start here at zero so
zero one two
three
four
five and we could go below zero we'd
have negative one negative two
negative three
negative four i could keep going now we
want we wanna graph all of the x's that
are less than four but we're not
including four it's not less than or
equal to four it's just less than four
and to show that we're not going to
include four what we're going to do is
we're going to draw a circle around four
so this shows us that we're not
including 4 if we were including 4 i
would make that a solid dot and to show
that we're going to do all of the values
less than 4 we want to shade in the
number line below 4 going down from 4
just like that
and then we can just
shade in the arrow just like that so
this right here is all of the values
less than 4. and you could test it out
take any value where there's blue so
there's blue over here negative two
negative two is definitely negative two
is definitely less than four if you take
this value right here this two it's
definitely less than four four is not
included because 4 is not less than 4
it's equal to 4 5 is not included
because 5 is not less than 4.